so well the simple version is just to
tell you what the terms in the equation
mean which is the e means energy and
that's equal to M mass times C the speed
of light squared energy can be measured
in joules mass of a particle could be
measured in kilograms so if you're going
to relate then you have to relate them
with some factor and the factor that
does it is this square of the speed of
light taken at face value it means that
energy is equivalent to mass so that if
you were to look at Newton's laws of
motion and say that masses attract this
now implies that energy is attracted by
a another mass so if the light wave with
energy goes near a planet or the Sun
it's actually bent by it because it's
attracted so it's saying that energy is
equivalent to match the consequence of
it is quite dramatic because the speed
of light squared is a huge number the
speed of light in meters per second is
three times ten to the eighth 300
million meters per second you square
that and you've got rubbish there nine
times ten to the 16 so you have order 10
to the 17 as a conversion factor so a
very small amount of mass is equivalent
to a huge amount of energy
physical terms what it means is that
there is actually an energy associated
with mass it's something that just sort
of falls out sort of almost
automatically from special relativity
that it's just something that comes out
of the equations but obviously it's an
incredibly powerful result because it
basically means that whenever you've got
a mass you have a source of energy and
so you know if you're good if you have a
fusion bomb for example you actually
convert some of that mass directly into
energy but it basically is another way
of saying that mass is just a way of
storing energy but it's not even the
right equation the proper equation is e
squared equals M Squared C to the fourth
plus another term involving the momentum
which is an extra P squared C squared
the mass in equals MC squared can either
be the rest mass and that's what it's
usually thought of that's where the the
object isn't moving and so it's actually
just got an intrinsic mass and so it's
got an intrinsic energy associated with
it or it could be what's known as the
relativistic mass and if it's the
relativistic mass then it's including
the momentum and I think I'm probably
agreeing with Roger in the textbooks
you'll often see the the the bare mass
is M with a little subscript zero beside
it just to make it clear that that's not
including the momentum of the particle
the whole equation is never explained
because people like you don't want us to
write down equations because they're
boring haha but if you do it all
properly that's what it is and if you
don't do it properly then you can't
explain what my Energy's attracted to
gravitationally to object nor can you
explain how a photon which doesn't have
any mass behaves the way it does I think
an interesting aspect is why is it the
square of the speed of light why isn't
it the square of the speed of sound
which is a much lower number and for
that you have to look at what I own
Stein did what Albert Einstein did when
he was coming up with this theory of
special relativity without any extra
work it sort of falls out of the
analysis of special relativity that it's
just a result that comes along and it's
very nice when you just get a result
that just sort of falls out without any
extra work but actually on its own has
it
huge amazing implications for the laws
of physics the people I've spoken to and
when I give public talks the people who
attend it certainly have an idea that
you've got energy in nasty I don't think
they often realize quite how significant
it is and quite how broad that equation
is in explaining phenomena that we
experience they they just tend to think
of it in the world of particle physics
or something rather rather extreme but
in fact it accounts for the binding of
atoms right if you've got the
constituents of atoms and you just you
just measure their mass then you put
them together the mass drops and and
then the mass drops because of the
binding energy and the thing that
explains that binding energy is e equals
MC squared the correct equation even if
there were meant to be zero is e squared
equals MC to the fourth and if you take
the square root of that you can get
negative energies coming out and Dirac
notice this and interpreted the negative
energy states as the anti particles so
you now get something for nothing if you
use the correct equation you can take
the square root come out with a negative
energy solution and then interpret in
quantum mechanics as the antiparticle
and he predicted this well before
anybody did the experiment and discover
the positron so the proper equation is
much richer the public can't cope with
anything more complicated than equals MC
squared and even that's so full of
meaning